I want to make a very special
announcement here I'm excited to say
that
um I have the crab Feast podcast back
under my control okay so uh it's every
artist's goal to get their you know
property back to them we got it all
right so
um
if you don't know about the crab Feast
um but a lot of you do I want to say
this I'm on the road meet and greets
people come up been rocking with you
since the feast man the feast the feast
the crab Feast is a podcast that I did
with Jay Larson it's a storytelling
podcast Audio Only
um we did it for about seven and a half
years there's 350 some episodes hell if
you if you listen to two a week it would
take you three and a half years to get
through it but it's a phenomenal library
that I'm very proud of
um it's what
um proceeded the Honeydew for me
um and it's got all the same favorite
guests you love sagora Bert Kreischer
Bill Burr Christina p uh you name it
there's and they're all different
stories too so if you love the Honeydew
you gotta check out the crab Feast
um subscribe to it today it's still
getting a ton of downloads already
there's an active community on Facebook
that goes through every episode uh and
it's been almost gone for four years
years now so
um feasters let them know uh honeydew
fans if you are looking for you're all
caught up on a honeydew and you're like
what else can I listen to I'm telling
you go listen to The Crab Feast it is a
fantastic fun uh storytelling podcast
you know there you'll get like man I got
this weird ghost story in a near death
and a marriage story into this where
that's what you know I the Honeydew for
me was the crab fees needed to have a
baby and I just focus on highlighting
the low lights here so go check it out
it's available everywhere you get
Podcast it's audio only like I said
subscribe
um join the fan pages have fun with it
I'm going to be promoting it every week
here on the Honeydew now that it's uh
back in in control here so I'm very
excited about that thank you feasters
thank you honeydew fans enjoy the feast
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night
pants Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
starting every show uh this way and then
this is the last one of 22 y'all so
thank you very much whether you're new
here or whether you've been here I
appreciate the support from day one if
you are watching on the YouTubes hit
that subscribe button that's what we
want that's our New Year's resolution to
get more subscribers on this channel
it's a freeway to help the show
um also uh check out that crab feast all
right crab Feast if you're looking for a
new podcast check out this old one seven
year Library
all your favorite comedians completely
different stories
um go check that out all right now as I
said this is the last episode of 2022
and you guys know we do over here we
highlight the low lights I'm very
excited to have this guest back on the
do to uh do a do review ladies and
gentlemen Josh what's up what's going on
man first of all I I am every time I
hear you say night pants it makes me
real happy thank you man it makes me
real because
I gotta say you were the you were the
straw that broke the camel's back I
don't know that I'd go forward with uh
actually starting my own [ __ ]
um fashion line I'ma call it a fashion
line it is I see more people in night
pants now than when they're walking
around I'm like Oh my pants you like do
the Honeydew yeah
um all right well
I'm gonna explain to everybody uh what
we're gonna do here so we're gonna take
a break for a change of highlighting our
low lights and uh this worked out so
well last time we're gonna do this again
this is our little end of the year show
where uh you and I are gonna review
um some of my favorite low lights from
my patreon show the Honeydew with y'all
I will tell you the last one and and you
and I have both done a ton of podcasts
our own other people's
top three favorite podcasts I've ever
done dude because you know I like I know
you like this I love this show I was
like I just I'll build around your
schedule
I love this [ __ ] well we have some
exciting stuff for you and you uh but
the patreon so you know it's called the
Honeydew with y'all and I highlight the
low lights with y'all we've been doing
it now
for a few years okay and I'm keeping the
show at five bucks I've never raised it
once I'm not gonna raise it again this
year it's five dollars if you want to
sign up for the year you'll get over a
month free you get the Honeydew a day
early you get it ad free you get it at
no additional cost all right and if you
or someone you know has a story that has
to be heard please submit at the
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully
we'll get to do some episodes together
um now we chose and again these are no
order like a top ten right these are
just 10 of our faith there's there's so
many we've done hundreds of these
episodes we only did 11 last time we
gave you a bonus here's 10 this time uh
so we're talking 21 and these are just
moments from each of these episodes and
I go an hour I don't I don't I don't
[ __ ] yeah I don't dog these fans I
treat these fans like they're you or Tom
Segura you're getting an hour with me
um and we have some fun so uh before uh
we get into that please plug promote
everything Josh Wolf okay first of all
this weekend if you're in Tempe and
there are still tickets left I will be
at the Tempe Improv I'm there with my
son Jacob
um this is the New Year's Eve shows uh I
only have a host to 10 minutes and then
it's a bananas show I have guests it's a
it's a Bonanza Extravaganza but it's a
good time man last year's show sold out
so if you're in the area come through
um if you're in New Zealand in Australia
Jacob and I will be there the second
half of January all this stuff is on
comediennejoshwolf.com and
um my shows in February in Nashville at
Zanies are also almost sold out already
so if you want to come come get some the
real thing I would love you all to check
out which is free free it's a show that
I do with my son Jacob called family
tussle yeah on my YouTube channel I will
tell you man and I've told you this
before I think it's the best thing I've
ever done not just the production value
and and the and everything we put into
it
but like it's like the reason you like
jackass or Impractical Jokers is you
like seeing people who love each other
[ __ ] around with each other that's like
do you know what I mean you love yeah
you love seeing that because there's a
certain there's no lines you you can't
hurt each other's feelings everything's
on the table yes yeah and you the some
of the things that like so it's he and I
compete with in contests and the loser
has to do something terrible now he made
me get a tattoo on my back oh you didn't
see that uh-uh what is that I saw the
ass waxing I watched everything well
they watched every bit of that I didn't
know you got a tattoo yeah it says Jacob
is my biological dad
where is it right on my shoulder man
yeah
what did you lose to have to get that oh
I lost that boxing no yo dude he
peppered me he did he Peppa he's the law
he's long and like you know what it is
man so we're in the ring together and
you know about our age you don't realize
the difference because you still feel
like oh I feel good I would see a Punch
coming and I'd be able to tell my head
to move and it just didn't you know what
I mean sitting in time that's what I
mean well it moved after he hit it yeah
you know so he peppered me pretty good
um but you know I did some things to him
man so the way we torture each other is
different you can't embarrass me so but
he would do things my punishments were
physical I watched his asked me about
Herpes missing out on a good community
so it's so much fun man and the and the
clips are anywhere from six to eight
minutes we had some crazy guests your
episode is coming out the beginning of
the year okay good
um but we had some great guests from
Freddie Prince Jr to Seth Green and
Chelsea Lynn came and did one with us
and yeah so it it is it's amazing if you
guys check it out it's on my YouTube
channel and here's the thing for me
I listened to a bunch of execs and
people tell me why it wasn't gonna be
good and so guys like you and Segura
you're inspirational in that I was like
wow why don't why am I listening I'm
just gonna do it myself
so self-funded self-produced yeah so
every from beginning to end it all came
out of my little brain that's one of the
other reasons why I'm most proud of this
because I saw it in my head I was like
[ __ ] you people this is funny well when
you present an idea to most people in
this industry first of all they do not
have the hustle we have right they do
not have the heart we have they do not
have the drive we have so the immediate
reaction from them is let me give you
six reasons why it won't work okay I sat
in a sushi restaurant the other day by
myself listen to these two guys this guy
was hungry for a graphics job as a video
game they were having a conversation
about it and this dude just like yeah
you know he's got to do a proof of
concept and I'm like I wanted to turn
around and be like don't go work for
this clown you'll be his boss in two
years this guy doesn't know what to say
to you he just wants you to do all the
work and then bring you something that's
TurnKey and then he can attach his
[ __ ] name to it and take credit for
it do you know what no you know what we
used to need them for is distribution
that's legit we needed them to have our
stuff together we don't need their job
but we don't need them for that right
well what we did need you for was to do
your job yeah well that's all I needed
just to do your part of this yeah yeah
yeah I'm doing everything else yeah you
do that part now we don't even need you
to do that part
so it feels good not for you guys yes it
feels for you but I'm excited man I'm
doing the same thing with my special all
the power back in my hand self-funded
doing it all I don't care I did this I
don't even want to bother trying because
even if I get it I'll worry about it on
on the next one if I it'll be four
months of pitches five months of uh
contracts and lawyers and legal and I'm
like we got this thing would have been
out for six months but yo not only that
they're gonna give you notes on your
comedy [ __ ] yeah you you I can't have
people who aren't funny telling me what
they think is funny no because not only
that man
what they think is funny you know your
audience right so they're telling you
it's funny that like I know who what my
audience likes I know who's watching
yeah they're my audience they're my
audience that's why they like me and
I've worked really hard right so don't
yeah yeah but yeah man I'm psyched well
I'll tell you what I'm proud of you and
you have worked hard and I've worked
hard yeah so why don't we sit back now
can't wait and relax a little here and
uh we'll just go ahead and highlight
some of the low lights from the Honeydew
with y'all on my patreon okay uh first
guy here he's back he's uh he's a
favorite his name is Mike Frampton
um we call him the death janitor oh I
remember this guy yeah yeah he was
wearing a Christmas sweater last time we
saw him this is from that episode this
guy's got [ __ ] we only heard a
snippet yeah this guy's got stories for
days okay days he's the most popular
um Patron on the patreon and he's a
death janitor Mike Frampton cleans up
crime scenes dead bodies things that
that the corners and everyone else don't
take away right so uh this first one
here uh is a little bit about hoarders
this is a little story about hoarders
here I wanted you to check out we'll
just kick it off this is a fun one just
a fun one
there was piles my buddies Corey hadn't
seen anything like this and he says to
me
what am I looking at like what is what's
in the sink and I said that's [ __ ] and
he goes no it's not and I was like well
the guy's hoarded his bathroom over
there where would he go like there's no
shame you don't get to stop [ __ ] so
if you hoard your bathroom you got to
figure that out Home Depot buckets we
had people get so desperate
cut a hole in the floor in their living
room and just [ __ ] into the basement
into the basement dude so what happened
what are these on the second floor
that's the problem they don't think
about it they hoard themselves into a
corner and usually it's into a bathroom
and then once they hoard themselves in
there it's the fast food and everything
coming they can't get out to cook or
anything it's delivery and then it just
piles up and they have to [ __ ] and they
filled the toilet they filled the sink
they filled the tub caught a hole in the
floor power [ __ ] down and let me ask
you a question let me hold on let me ask
you a question the first time you [ __ ]
in the sink so first do you know what I
mean yeah are you like I'm just gonna do
this one time yeah you you'd be like oh
I might want to make a pass
I might want to just clear yeah my
instinct wouldn't be like you know I
should cut a hole I would be like I
should maybe pick one of these things
by the way you know how bad you gotta
[ __ ] if you're like I gotta cut this
hole
[Music]
isn't there like wires and and pipes and
do you know what I mean like it's not
just something you care if you gotta
shut up
hahaha
dude but so why not just walk downstairs
into the basement most of the time these
people are also obese and they can't so
they're just sort of just you know like
a trapped animal they're just backing
into the cage I got a question for you
sure
when you're that fat and you're a
hoarder
How could a job you think he's doing
wiping that out he's not you think he's
reaching that ass
definitely not you think he wipes it on
the carpet like a dog he just kind of
scooches around the floor he is too but
he just got a hole in them
and do you think okay I got another
question do you think he comes in an
area rug for toilet paper that's
ridiculous
do you think he hovers or he cuts a hole
big enough for his ass to sit on it um
well let's see if he tells us anymore
here we've had a couple that did that
where they just took a Sawzall and just
cut a [ __ ] hole and just down the
hole of ghosts you know this guy fills
his sink he fills his toilet filled his
toilet to the point where like this guy
had to [ __ ] stand on the side of his
tub and on his sink to get over the [ __ ]
pile to get the [ __ ] to land on top no I
had to take a contractor bag and it
filled it the whole thing all the way
down
and then we had to push the [ __ ]
over in the bag
El if I'm working that job dude that's
new hey new guy
whoa Okay so
you hear what he's gonna say but how
come he never flushed it he's hoarding
his [ __ ] too yeah yeah so ignored the
[ __ ] I actually experienced this in in
my life when I worked at a hotel I
worked at a Beverly Hills Hotel called
the Beverly Prescott back in the day at
Kempton property great Hotel one of my
favorite Hotel property chains Kimpton
dog friendly
and uh it might be pet friendly and um
we had a hoarder come in and she did the
same thing she
um would [ __ ] in the toilet and it piled
up outside over the rim
um
it was a lot it was a weekend's worth
she was there and just [ __ ] Non-Stop
and in her mind when they took her out
um they were telling us that they killed
her
though you sound like a sniper took her
they should have they [ __ ] escorted I
mean she was taken out by
um the hospital you know they came to
get her
um she also the other problem too with
her was she was loaded she was at
Beverly Hills Lane she lived close to
the hotel and Jerry's Deli would just
deliver to her all the time so when the
delivery guys will come in they would
tell us about her like you don't
understand dude she's got newspapers
covering her front porch ceiling the
um floor and and just like you can't
even get in so she'll take a break and
come over there and hoard over in that
room because she had the money to do it
right uh but she would not flush her
[ __ ] because mentally it was a part of
her and she just couldn't get rid of
that so she would hoard her [ __ ] too
yeah
it's so
I'm not a doctor
but I am a podcaster the patreons
sign up for a year so a couple of months
a couple they would [ __ ] in the hole
together
no no no he's saying a couple different
people oh oh yeah he's had a couple
people do yo you you you probably can't
keep a friend a relationship
do you know what I mean like if I had a
friend who just came over and never
flushed their [ __ ] I'd be like yo what
what are we doing man you would smell
that house before you got in that house
I can't believe it you know what's crazy
is that like
the concept of hoarding to Me Maybe I
throw too much [ __ ] up I don't know
about you but I'm like I if I haven't
used something in a month I'm like I
don't need that anymore [ __ ] that I'm a
big donator I donate a lot of [ __ ] dude
but like
yo when you walk into somebody's house
and there's a hole in the floor
so they could [ __ ] why why not just take
a torch and be like you know what
everybody
we're gonna we're gonna this is a
Reclamation project we're just gonna
light this [ __ ] [ __ ] on fire right I
think because also they're so big
they've backed themselves into a room
they can't get out anymore
you know what I mean they can't get out
of there they're done they're in there
they're gonna die
you know you could I bet you find the
[ __ ] Declaration of Independence of
one of those people's houses you know
what I'm saying well I'll tell you what
we're gonna move on to clip number two
here but before we get into clip number
two let me ask you this uh Josh Wolf
have you ever had uh a bike wreck you
ever wreck your bike I wrecked my moped
once
was it the pedal start like old oh yo no
I used to have one of those I was
probably 20 or 21. uh By the way when I
had this moped Ryan did you own it or
was this a rental you were out having
fun owned it okay was this a Vespa or is
this a moped moped okay now listen
the the muffler broke and so it sounded
like oh it's like yeah yeah it sounded
like a Harley and so when I would come
down the street people would look and
thought it was a Harley and it was just
me and I'm open but not only that at
that time in my life I was working at
children's parties you know costumes
yeah and the guy who owned the company
wouldn't let you show up and change
because he didn't want the kids to see
you out of costume so I had to drive
with my mobile
what characters are showing up on the
moped let me tell you something the guy
assigned me three characters and one of
them was Peter Pan
I'm dressed like Peter Pan and a cop
pulls up to me
he looks he rolls out the window and he
goes hey man I go yeah you guys I was
gonna give you a ticket for no helmet
but it looks like your life's going bad
enough as it is
looks like you're in the [ __ ] or [ __ ]
drove away and I was like yeah
but I I dumped that moped once
you know what were your injuries oh I
skinned up that entire left side of my
some Road rack yeah yeah my hand yeah
but luckily for the cop I was wearing a
helmet there you go because it happened
after that but I was dressed like a
clown when I crashed when you cry it was
really embarrassed when the EMT came and
he was like what the [ __ ] is it was a
moped and a bloody clown and he was like
this is like my nightmare but yeah it
was it was not great but nothing too bad
well
um this is Andrew Curtis Here Andrew
Curtis uh he wrecked his bike and um I'm
gonna let him tell us about his accident
and it's like one of those like single
outhouses and I locked the door and I
was just like in a panic in this and I
was like checking myself and I was like
I don't see any Cuts or anything so I
pulled my swim shorts down to my ankles
and when I looked at my I don't know how
to put it nicely when I looked at my
dick there was it you know like when you
overcook a bratwurst
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we'll just go ahead and stop there
laughs
[ __ ] your road rash dude
dick looks like an overcooked bratwurst
oh my God
yo how big is your Panic if your dick
looks like that he [ __ ] went down
face first and did the road rash on the
body and that's when he was like oh I
don't I think I'm okay I don't see
anything and then he pulled his pants
down I was like ah and his dick is now
looks like an overcooked bratwurst but
let's hopefully it's just it's swollen
let's see what hap what's actually going
on with it here okay it was even doing
the little like
oh
he's a squirmer dude
oh no it's not good did it recover
that's not good for him right now okay
hey you gotta subscribe to the patreon
that's five dollars
wait you are by the way this episode
these first two you've got your five
dollars worth
like I don't know I don't know wait so
did how does it look now did he have to
have like plastic surgery uh he had he's
gonna he's gonna tell you a little bit
about it like I panicked I I didn't know
what to do I was like a soldier holding
his dying buddy on the battlefield like
holding them like oh my God you're gonna
be okay
you're gonna be okay he's saying to his
own dick
he's saying it to his own dick his
Dick's like to my parents
oh
oh okay keep going Curry we went right
into this like numbing or I don't know
what they gave me but it was a shot and
he grabbed it and he literally just went
no he he didn't give me a countdown
right like into my like yeah no no no no
no
no
warning MC s bratwurst dick that squirt
blood
oh
this is the worst biker I've ever heard
yo dude this is the best advertisement
for Uber I've ever heard him
oh wait wait I'd wear a cup every time I
hopped on that bike yo a needle in the
dick right in the urethra bro write down
your dick hole with no warning they they
were they saw what was happening there
like we gotta get we gotta numb it and
get surgery on this by the way so be
fair if they had given a warning he'd
have been like [ __ ] yeah he would have
been you fight you can't be like hey I'm
gonna stick this needle in your dick
hole you'd be like nah what are the
other options I need to hear option two
and three the good news is what's the
there's good news there's more to the
story but it's uh they were able to
um repair it like the Six Million Dollar
dick
maybe six million well let's listen I
don't want to spoil here you said from
your abdomen is where the stitches
started
yeah pretty much like they went all the
way from like the top all the way to
like where it like hits my body it
pretty much went all the way up through
there through like over around the tip
and just like barely around the other
half so kind of like candy cane shape
they stitched
candy canes this is the government
just Christmas
it was just Christmas
wait let me add is it the same shape as
it used to be same size well I'm gonna
tell you this much
those answers
are on the page sign up to the patreon
five dollars a month okay okay okay can
I if someone was gonna get in there
right
do you have options can you be like
listen can you bulk it up a little bit I
would be too yeah right as long as we're
in there can we make the mushroom head a
little fast
just make it real weird like those new
big hats yeah you know that dude on Fat
Albert that has that hat that's what I
wanted
I don't mind if the shaft is thin
foreign
nothing happened to his nuts no the nuts
were okay it was all belly and [ __ ] just
took the brother the dick was like
yeah his dick ripped open dude
okay
all right we're just getting started can
I ask one more question how did the bike
accident happen do you know I don't
remember how he wrecked I don't he must
have gone over the handlebars right and
just landed like I can't remember if
that or if he like uh went down and just
skid I can't remember but you got to
watch it because I would imagine also
yeah
you ever hit that bar in the middle
oh yeah oh yeah like that is that seems
like an [ __ ] nut accident waiting to
happen all right
um well speaking of accidents we have um
a tragic one here we're about to discuss
um this gentleman this young gentleman
here is named Andy Schmidt Andy Schmidt
uh he died
he died
um interesting enough his death is Rule
to Drowning you're going to hear the
story though but I'm gonna set it up so
his buddy's driving another friend in
the passenger seat and Andy is in the
back behind the driver in the pickup
truck and his buddy sitting across from
him
they're driving along this the edge of a
lake so it's just a little Marsh and
they look what's about to they think is
a cliff or a ditch and the guy goes to
Veer off
and as they do his dogs in the back with
Andy and the dog goes to jump and
instinctually and he goes to grab the
dog and save him so when he goes to get
the dog the truck tips
um and as it tips it rolls over on Andy
and it pins him under it face down and
that other dude's dick enters his mouth
and that's when his disc the dog started
humping him around could you imagine the
dog is ass right
he is Face Down Under the truck but the
thing is because they're on the edge of
that water he's actually in a in in face
down in water and he's drowning but he
doesn't know it he thinks he is he's he
just needs to lift his head up but he
doesn't realize that he's pushing it
down so he's jamming his own face worse
because he's all flipped around he
doesn't know he thinks he's trying to
lift his head up and as he's there
um his buddies are grabbing them they've
got his legs and they're trying to pull
him out from underneath this truck they
realize he's drowning and dying there's
nothing they can [ __ ] do and he is
kicking his [ __ ] legs like a
[ __ ] Okay that's what's
happening right now this is not a funny
as sausage dick it's definitely not
so there's a moment where basically you
know your your debt you're gonna die it
is what it is that's where I stopped and
I prayed and I said
I said God either
you take me now and I'm A-Okay with it
I've had a good life
or
if I get through this I'm not going to
be in a hospital for the rest of my life
I said if you get me if you take if you
want me to keep going I'm doing it in
the hospital and
that's it that's all that's where it
ends for me so right there in that
moment you're able to be centered and
just have however long that even if it
was just a couple seconds you were able
to have that moment with yourself and
your maker okay this kid's Young have
you ever saved a life or had a
near-death experience I've definitely
had a near-death experience I I um
yo can I tell you something crazy about
that okay
I've been I'm not going to get into it I
told you earlier but I've I've been sick
recently and
um and tried to figure been really
trying to figure out what was wrong with
me and I've gone everywhere uh you've
heard a Reiki energy people
so I went to this woman and she said to
me hey were you in a car accident when
you were in high school and I said yeah
and she goes should you have died and I
go that's the EMTs came and no seatbelt
I hit a tree head on did you at 35 miles
an hour me and my buddy
we both hit the windshield and no joke
within three inches of each other but
for whatever reason Center neither one
of us went through it the EMTs always
were commented on that one of the MTS
was my youth football coach and when he
came and saw me in the hospital he said
it first I'm stunned you're both alive
but there's no way that neither one of
you got ejected from the car is crazy
so I went to this Reiki healer whether
you believe this [ __ ] or not I can just
tell you what happened okay
and she was like yeah she goes I see a
big shadow that protected you I'm like I
don't know and she mentioned a name
and I go I don't know that person but I
reached out to my friend who was in that
accident with me and I go you're never
gonna he and she was like well this I
don't know I can just tell you what I'm
seeing big person I but my buddy was a
huge person
and um I said does this name mean
anything to you because that's my
grandfather no
that's my grandfather
and I was like dude I'm just going to
tell you that the this healer I went to
this random lady who doesn't know who
the [ __ ] either you this healer I went
to said that this Guardian Angel was the
reason neither one of us went through a
windshield it was a long silence and he
was like I gotta go I go yeah me too but
send me your name yeah dude it [ __ ]
it was crazy this happened recently dude
so many banana things have happened to
me recently that have made me rethink
life but that one and this woman that's
crazy it blew me the [ __ ] away dude blew
me away but yeah so that one experience
where I always thought something worse
should have happened to hear that
whatever 30 40 years later was [ __ ]
crazy yeah you know also that you're
still alive and you were able to live
long enough for that to Circle back to
you bananas all right yeah
so this young gentleman is dead under
the truck right now he's let's listen to
the rest of his story
as this right as this happens after the
truck flips they see it Jake and Matt
stay with me and Owen the younger
brother just went running down the road
screaming as loud as he could
100 feet up the road from where we
flipped nurse and a firefighter camping
camping
but this is let me ask you something
and Peter some people would call it
coincidence
is that where you follow you call that
coincidence you know what I call it
immediately suspicious
a nurse and a firefighter to me sound
like you're having an affair yeah that's
right middle of [ __ ] nowhere and they
were like come save maroon yeah and they
were like we can't we actually we can't
only one of them I was like
I was like I'll wait to hear what
happens wait to hear that the nurse in
the fire so
excuse me his friends
have done everything they can to pull
him out he has died in their arms so his
he his legs go lifeless in their arms
they know their friend's dead under that
truck then they were one kid runs up the
hill and just starts screaming and here
comes a [ __ ] out of nowhere a goddamn
nurse and a fire by the way this is all
happening while he's dead dead
these two immediately come down this
firefighter I swear this dude could have
been on like three shots of roids this
dude
[ __ ] massive
so this dude and my two buddies flip the
truck now
did this dude turn green before he
flipped the truck
yo The Rock shows yeah right and now
they are able to flip this truck off
with his big steroided ass doing it but
lit but the girls the woman he's with
the girlfriend or whoever she's to him
is a nurse
the trucks this guy like [ __ ] Rogan
walked out of the boat
these guys and this isn't like this is
all happening while you're dead by the
way yeah I'm giving up I'm giving up you
and your legs are dead so
[Applause]
now
now did you ask him was he cross-eyed
before the accident
you can tag them also
here's what I want to ask you though
yeah how long do you think he was dead
the nurse was able to time death how
long do you think
well isn't like bad [ __ ] what's the
timing where like I mean 100 yards and
100 yards down
yo I don't know how quickly you can run
100 yards but like I'm not the rock yeah
yeah
I'm this guy
[Laughter]
all right I listen
he's dead for two minutes
not bad it's actually dead for three and
a half [ __ ] minutes
yo there's dead he's he's not they're
supposed to be permanent [ __ ] three and
a half minutes and you gotta listen to
the episode to uh hear the rest of it
listen really died that's not only by
the way that's the minimum the second
there I think we've had three or four
people that have died on that have you
have you ever had a near death yeah I've
had several near-death experiences
um but nothing like that I wasn't pinned
I almost got hit by a truck and wiped
out like mangled so I got lucky but
nothing like this nothing where I was
even unconscious for that I mean that's
it's a while bro to be dead yeah dude no
pulse nothing he's flatlined there and
he's a firefighter and she's a nurse so
they know and he's helping do CPR while
he's doing dollars a month it ain't
going nowhere he was doing push-ups
while he was doing this
now
yo that is
Yeah a hundred percent that changes how
I live my life from here on out
don't you think I asked them do you
still keep in touch with these people he
said yep he does thanks I'm like you're
alive because of them he's like yeah are
they still [ __ ]
that's a good question bro I don't know
I think you were out at him uh all right
so this next one is another fan favorite
you might recognize her from last time
also her name is Randy kioski she is a
uh she went from yeah I love her gang
banging to uh Dominatrix and I want to
be very clear gang banging you could
clearly think it meant sexually but this
was actually in a gang yeah then shifted
into uh being a dominatrix I love how
casually she talks about this stuff
she's super casual about it she's
relocated to Nashville for any of you
out there come to my shopping Matrix
yeah uh she's great she's gonna tell us
um some wild [ __ ] just curious whatever
what's the freakiest thing you've done
sexually that you're comfortable talking
about like what would you say was
something where you you know pushed your
limits okay
okay
it's like [ __ ] like an old lady
well here's the thing man I don't know
how don't say who with and you don't
have to if you don't want to yeah you
know get something where it doesn't
matter what age you were just something
where you were like I got a little
experimental or whatever there yeah yeah
okay when when
when I was okay one would say when
because I don't wanna yeah but there was
a girl I was with who was always talking
about threesomes
and I was like yeah I'm I'm down for
female female male
that is 100 because here's my thing I
had done a male male female with a buddy
of mine you did and I kept laughing at
his [ __ ] face I couldn't take it
seriously because we were facing each
other and he was he was doing the
whatever I was like and I said in the
middle I go is that your face is that
what you're gonna do the whole time I
can't look at you man do you know what I
mean he was I think he had watched too
much Peter North or something you know
what I mean because he was and I was
like come on man like we're here
together so let's have a little fun or I
am out skiing on this
well
she was a little freakier than I was and
I was like I'm not into this and she was
like come on let's try it one time try
one time and she was like have you ever
had a dude touch your dick I'm like nah
I don't want to do that that's not
something I'm interested she was like
just let him get close to it I was like
what does that means
if I'm [ __ ]
and he's right there on the other
right close yeah
yeah he's recorded close like he's close
enough right and
um
she was like how about if you let him if
if you're if you're [ __ ] me you let
him
like also lick around my puss in my
[ __ ] right and I was like that sounds
like he's gonna be licking my [ __ ]
and she was like no no I I just let him
get close to it it kind of turns me on
and so I was like
I go okay we can get close to it he got
a little too close to him
and I had to back out I was like listen
I told you this is not my she was like I
thought once we were in it you'd be fine
I go no I told you like that is not my
deal man do you know what I mean but
what I wanted your butt that's my mouth
yeah it was in my mouth because what I
wanted to tell myself is I'm not
homophobic and this is fine you know
what I mean and I don't think that makes
me homophobic that's just not something
that I was you don't like it it's
something I was like yeah I wasn't into
it it had been homophobic if you beat
him up or call them names just like
listen guys I'm gonna get out of here
yeah actually that is what I did yeah I
said hey everybody it's enough of that
it was almost like you know you walk
away from the blackjack table yeah good
luck gentlemen you know what you guys
good luck to everybody
yeah but that was maybe the freakiest
because I really was like I was in a
stage in my life where I wanted to not
Define anything I'd be like yeah [ __ ]
but I have made a definition that I
walked out of there with a hard that's
not something I'm into all right you
everyone has their their boundaries yeah
let's listen to one of uh Randy's
clients boundaries
at the place that I had in Chicago we
had a body bag that had a hole in it in
the mouth we would have you know
get-togethers and things like that and
we had a really high we call them white
whales which are really high paying
clients they came and he wanted all the
girls that I could find he said I don't
care if they're professionals or if
they're civilians I want as many girls
as you can find we'll pay them you know
anywhere from a hundred to seven
thousand dollars depending he's like
just don't go over like don't make it
crazy but try to talk him to be as you
know small amount as possible
I ended up getting around like I think
it was like 12 girls and they he laid in
this body bag which you suck body bags
tightly around you oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no that's me right now no no no no
no no because we're touching on a lot of
things a lot of things for me one I'm
claustrophobic is insane [ __ ] two death
is not that's not my nope that's not my
king there should only be one time
you're in that [ __ ]
that is it you know you should know
about it yeah
yo what this should be the last dude's
cake
well I'll tell you this is the beginning
of the king let's listen
you vacuum the air out yeah it's like
second skin on oh yeah so he's just got
the whole the hole in his mouth and we
put like you know those those
cone-shaped things that you pour oil in
into the car yeah right so we had like a
large one of those that went into his
mouth
now I'd like to ask you
what do you think happens next I think
they pee in the cone it's a solid guess
let me see Josh it's he says P but let
me ask you a question man
say a rich dude and he goes hey I'm
gonna get in this body bag I don't care
who it is and he puts a cone in his
mouth and he's like I'm gonna pay you
seven thousand dollars you peeing it
yeah
I'm peeing it and I'm [ __ ] taking
some shots in his ribs too on the way
out because he can't get out of that
[ __ ] airtight body bag
I'm painting that [ __ ] too yeah
yeah Seven Grand
is that what they did they painted
let's take a look and we all took uh
turns like pissing [ __ ] no into that
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay
okay
I have so many questions he swallows it
well let's listen
no it got to the point where he was no
wiggling because it got clogged I
couldn't breathe he couldn't breathe so
I we had to pull it out and he it was
like all over him all in his mouth he
was chewing it chewy
[Laughter]
dude I gagged on this episode
it's five dollars a month yo
got up for a year you get a month free
yo you do a thing earlier
who's good chewy [ __ ] like what well
there's a bunch of people and you're
pissing and [ __ ] to get it it's a
pope it's a [ __ ] jambalaya of
people's [ __ ] and piss this man is
eating it he's chewing it oh yo but what
when you eat [ __ ]
I know this is weird but what does your
[ __ ] look like
I mean I it's it depends on what I've
eaten like no what does his [ __ ] look
like if you're eating [ __ ] oh my shits
look like I was gonna get there
that's a great question
what if it's the most perfect [ __ ]
I don't know but here's how much he
loved it do you want to hear how much
this guy loved this
let's listen how do you find out that's
your thing he took a doggy bag of it
home no
laughs
[Music]
he took a doggy magnet
hey can I get something oh God can I get
some to go
like in a tupperware
you can keep Tupperware don't bring
don't wash it and bring it back what do
you carry [ __ ] home with
by the way
um do those people eat their own [ __ ]
that's I don't know I really don't know
I don't think it's about theirs it's
about other people's and not even seeing
like how do you find out yeah that's a
great question how do you find like
what's the okay you end up on [ __ ] but
what you what's the starting point you
know what I'm saying like like it you
don't jump to [ __ ] you don't go from me
and you to you know what [ __ ] in my
mouth this is the other thing too money
doesn't discriminate this guy's actually
yeah officially crazy but it loaded
loaded with money or what a white whale
they call him or a whale or whatever she
says guys
well you can't you can't be poor and
afford to have people [ __ ] in your mouth
that's a rich Bird yeah that's a rich
man that's right that's RPP man people's
game right there
the struggles we face with our mental
health can Loom large over our lives
maybe yours may be someone you love
you've tried everything or have you mind
Bloom is the solution for the next
chapter in mental health and well-being
mind Bloom is the leader in at-home
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of science-backed Medicine with
clinician and guide support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being mind Bloom connects
patients to licensed psychiatric
clinicians to help them achieve better
outcomes with lower cost greater
convenience and an artfully crafted
experience to begin you take mind
Bloom's online assessment mind Bloom
will send you a kit in the mail complete
with medicine treatment materials and
tips for getting the most out of your
experience after only two sessions 87
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in depression 85 reported
improvements in anxiety it is time to
enter the next chapter of mental health
and well-being let mind Bloom guide you
look I did this I didn't just do two I
did six and I I know it helped with my
anxiety I did it for anxiety it
absolutely helped with my anxiety so
right now mind Bloom is offering my
listeners 100 off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and you use the
promo code honeydew it checkout go to
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that is
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew tis the season to indulge but
if you don't want to get so high you go
to the Moon let that grass help you
chill out and enjoy the ride now
available for everyone in the family dad
mom dogs you and your loved ones can
chill out without getting them stoned to
the bone that grass is legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body and
Mellows your mind they're 100 organic
pre-rolled joints my favorite and flour
are very low in THC and high in CBD so
it can enjoy the effects of CBD while
keeping a clear head they offer a
variety of product so you can toke or
dose just the way you like from their
CBD tincture drops to the newly launched
CBD gummies and flavors like classic
Blackberry ginger good time hibiscus
lime and nighttime midnight bear you can
chill out without getting stoned and
that grass didn't forget your furry
friends they also just released CBD dog
bones all that grass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the U.S whether you're looking for a new
Buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite that grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now dad grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to daggrass.com
honeydew go to dadgrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com honeydew if your New Year's
goals are to manage your budget better
and save money you need rocket money
rocket money formerly known as true bill
is a personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forget about like that streaming
service you bought just to watch one
show on or that free trial that you
never even used rocket money will
quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want
rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button you simply find the subscription
you don't want you press cancel rocket
money will cancel it for you over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720 a
year all right I use it for all my uh
subscriptions I don't want just to make
sure for that exact thing I'll sign up
for that thing and it's after a month
and I get Bill Boom use it for
everything here at the studio too so if
you got a little small business or
something like that and you have all
these subscriptions men use it for that
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com honeydew that's
rocketmoney.com honeydew rocketmoney.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
this is a story I want to hear you tell
uh we're going to talk about this kid
Christian Pugh uh Christian Pugh has a
story that happened to him in Austin but
before we were recording you and I were
outside talking you said you actually
had a story very recently happened to
you and Austin I said you know what save
it let's hear your story and then we'll
hear Christians talk okay now listen
I know this is going to sound weird
coming off of the Reiki lady
but I'm in a hotel room in Austin
now I land that day
and I when I tell you I feel raged like
I've never felt before I was you can
still kind of see the knuckles I was
driving to my hotel room just punching
the roof of my rental car did you get
some news or no I just felt this crazy
[ __ ] rage like like I've never felt
before you know the car I'm glad I got
insurance on the car I kicked the [ __ ]
that car was dented all the way around
when I returned it they were like what
happened to this car and I was like
sorry about that deer yeah
about 12 of them right
I get into the hotel room
and all I'm going to tell you dude is
this is gonna sound whatever and it's
gonna it made me it makes me question
anything that I thought was real before
because I'm not this dude man I'm a very
grounded guy that's why the Reiki thing
[ __ ] me up too that's not where my
head lives I'm a science and all that
[ __ ] I need proof right
rage and I'm in my hotel room [ __ ]
just sitting on my bed and I don't know
why I said this because I just had a
feeling that like it felt like something
was just you're eating inside me
and I just said out loud because my Beth
is into this [ __ ]
I go hey if I
if there if I pick something up just get
I don't I don't want you
if I pick something because she's about
energy now I have to pick something up I
don't want you man
and all I can tell you is that it felt
like something
it just was holding on
so I said it out loud
if you if there's something here or
whatever because I'm still not believing
it but the more I start saying it the
more it feels like there's something
holding on
when I tell you it felt like I was in a
fight
for an hour in my hotel room with
something dude I was
saying things like get I know I I had
also ordered a pizza right right when I
first got in which was crazy but I dude
was
pushing down my arm it felt like I was
just trying and I was flicking saying
get the [ __ ] out of me I don't trying to
shed your skin I no it felt like
something was in me like and I was
saying things like I don't need you
anymore I don't [ __ ] need you anymore
and I was pushing and I was flicking I
was like get the [ __ ] out of me dude and
I don't know if this was psychosomatic
because of what was happening what
there's a mirror next to me when I
looked at that mirror dude you know
those horror movies when it looks like
their face changes
I'm just telling you what I saw whether
it happened or not what I saw
a morph and I'm saying things like get
the [ __ ] you know how crazy it got dude
I started screaming I rebuke you
like I was in the exorcism or some [ __ ]
dude I was screaming I rebuke you and I
started to hear them but this was funny
I started I heard a pounding I'm like I
rebuke you I rebuke you and then I just
heard I'll leave the pizza at the door
I was like
all right but I'm [ __ ] there were
times dude where I would feel exhausted
and I would lay back and I would almost
feel it as I was sinking more I finally
felt like I I had whatever it was I had
gotten out of me
but I just still didn't feel alone when
I fell asleep I woke up two hours later
dude shot up with that same rage inside
of me and I just started screaming again
get the [ __ ] out of me dude when I went
like this
to try to get my head around what was
happening there were guttural sounds
coming out of my mouth I don't make dude
I don't do voices I don't know if you've
ever heard me do voices on chaos I don't
do voices I don't know how to make
guttural noises I don't know how to make
what sounds like a growl there were
noises coming out of me that I just
can't [ __ ] explain and when I after
the second time when it finally when I
finally felt lighter it felt like the
whole room was lighter like lighter like
it was finally gone now there have been
two explanations for me
one
we meet so many people
that like people who believe in
somebody's bolt some [ __ ] jumped on
you we meet so many people that
everybody's energy and somebody's energy
just took a ride with you which I don't
look I do believe that at all no there
was another dude who was in the service
who was like you know military dudes go
through sometimes when you push
something down when you repress a
feeling for so long it can come out in a
physical form and I believe that to be
true also but I know what I've I know
what [ __ ] happened to me and I'm
still in between on what I feel like but
dude physically my hands looked bigger
my face changed that noise and I I still
don't know exactly where to put it it's
[ __ ] me up a little bit dude because
now I told you two days later I called
my wife I'm like hey just making sure I
called you right she's like yeah what's
going on I'm like I'm just making sure
I'm not crazy like I want to make sure
that what's happening in my life is
actually happening but like because
that's not [ __ ] that I tend to believe
in but
but but I know what happened I know who
I am I know I wasn't high on mushrooms
like none of that [ __ ]
it whatever it was man was a
life-changing
eye-opening experience for me like I now
am open to so many ideas of things like
maybe yeah [ __ ] maybe that's right I
don't even know why not yeah [ __ ]
maybe but I rebuke you dude was was like
that's the only thing I knew to scream
I've seen The Exorcist you know what I
mean like but it was crazy do you
anything like like you believe you a
ghost dude do you believe in that [ __ ]
I've had experiences for sure where you
know I believe in spirits and souls and
all that [ __ ] yeah I mean I don't
believe in Casper and you know yeah kind
of harps and Angels like the winged yeah
but yeah but I believe in whatever that
term is whatever that entity is I have a
version of that that I believe for me
for sure yeah dude if it was like yeah
that'll make you question everything
come on man wait to hear this story
Joshua
this young gentleman's name is Christian
Pugh all right Christian
uh went to Austin
originally for something that he'll tell
you about and went out after with his
friends partying
and
let's take a listen so I had a traumatic
brain injury
um I had I think three or four cracked
ribs punctured lungs and then a broken
wrist and then yeah I already said
dislocated leg
okay well yeah then dislocated like
that's a break
did he not put his dildo away what is
that a giant Green Incredible Hulk deal
though what is that over there
wait this guy's got bigger problems
trust me a dislocated leg that means oh
these are his injuries yeah out of the
socket out of everything now
the problem is uh besides all those
things yeah let it go ahead and let it
play so wait you walk away and then boom
you're found
no so I was found 65 hours after oh my
God
I'm confused he walks away from where
he's with his friends about to tell you
where he what he's in Austin for he's
just gonna tell us right now but but
after that event he's out drinking with
a group of friends and he gets so wasted
he doesn't know if he's drugged he
doesn't know anything but he wanders
away from his group just wanders
aimlessly away there's a bank that
catches the last seconds of him walking
away
and then he goes missing for three days
there's a full-on search party out
looking for this [ __ ] poor kid he's
found under the Congress Street Bridge
okay but here's the thing he doesn't
know that he's in a coma so he's found
three days later by this police search
party but he doesn't wake up for another
month in the hospital
but listen to why he's in Austin
so I was in town to see Tom Segura of
all people
for three days
disagreeing tickets to his next show
definitely telling him this and it was
crazy because like I said earlier they
couldn't report me missing 448 hours so
they couldn't even put a notice out or
anything like my parents my parents know
for a fact like something's wrong right
they were like because my parents were
supposed to go see a girl with me
I swear to God like
so at that point I'm like I'm [ __ ]
call on top yeah and I just give it a
shot I FaceTime Tom Tom
Christian went to see you in Austin and
after the show his parents were also
supposed to go with them to see you in
Austin Texas and after the show he got
drunk
and wandered off from his group was
found three days later under the
Congress Street Bridge he still doesn't
know that and he woke up a month later
dude he went to see you in concert and
was missing for three days found under
the Congress Street bridge still not
still blacked out and one month later
this [ __ ] woke up and he's about
to tell me his story right now
yo the Congress Street bridge is that
the one with the bats that's the one
with the bats I asked him did you
covered in bat [ __ ] he's like no some
homeless dude pointed him out to the
police that he's over there
did they tell does anybody know how he
got there
watch the episode oh you gotta tell to
watch the episode that yo so first of
all
at this point though the police don't
know if he's thrown off the bridge they
don't know if he'd been robbed and
mugged and tossed they don't know if he
was so [ __ ] up and blacked out he
walked right and fell off they don't
know he didn't he doesn't know it's a
month later before they can get any kind
of answers out of him uh because he's in
a coma
I mean all because he wanted to go see
Thomas yes Agora did say tell him I'll
give him free tickets next time he comes
wait but but his parents have to pay but
like
oh wait so he fell off the bridge
pre-concert or post post he got the seed
Tom
yeah and then went drinking after it and
then that's what happened to him does he
have any after a month in a coma any
permanent any things he first of all you
heard him say did I mention the thing
and I'm like no you didn't mention that
yeah so when he's talking to Tom on the
phone there Tom goes what happened I
said I don't know he says he doesn't
know while later in the episode he's
like so anyway and he says what happened
I go hold on you just said you didn't
know he goes I did I go you just told
Tom segora and me you didn't know what
happened how you ended up there he's
like oh no I know how I got there and I
started laughing I'm like dude yeah yeah
definitely
you definitely
by the way you know the only good thing
about brain damage is probably if in
your relationship you know what I'm
saying you can be like I
forgot yeah did I say that to you yeah I
have no idea all right this next one
here is a little fun one uh this is
named gentleman's name is Jordan Colette
uh Jordan is a deputy deputy coroner and
a funeral director
um and this dude has definitely seen
some [ __ ]
um and this particular one that we're
about to watch here is one of uh my
favorites from his story
I'm still Blown Away by that
yo both of those the dead dude and the
coma guy yo the body bag [ __ ] and
pissing
uh we had the [ __ ] in the basement
bike rack penis but it is five dollars a
month y'all you're on the way Long Haul
sign up for a year my correct penis
sounds like a great name for bands
I'm gonna go see bike rack penis at
Coachella bike well bike rack is nothing
compared to uh what Jordan Colette has
seen let's take let's take a listen and
watch this uh here a person passed away
in a uh car accident uh he was on the
interstate and the story we were told
was that he was I guess if I remember
correctly changing attire
you were gonna say that yep got too far
out and was hit by a car hauler one of
those 18-wheeler car haulers oh my God
so basically from the waist down it was
it was bad it wasn't good and uh so we
you know we come out and everything and
we're talking to one of the police
officers and uh
he says uh he's telling us what happened
you know broke down changed the tire and
uh you know gets out the road gets hit
by you know the car hauler and we said
how how do you know that how do you know
all this there's nobody else here and he
said he told us
not very long
for some of it
it caught him in half like a cockroach
and he stayed alive he was alive long
enough to get that story out and then he
let me ask you a question if you look
down on him in half he looked down and
you see no bottom half
what's I'm screaming I ain't [ __ ]
telling you what I must got out the
chains I mean that's all yeah that's all
shock and adrenaline doing that and
putting you on autopilot there yo but
have you seen those dudes
I mean
have you seen those dudes like with no
legs play hockey and [ __ ] you know
they're just the arms yeah yeah
that but they're badass but their arms
are like [ __ ] Jack yeah this dude is
just uh this dude was just done man it
got sawed in half and then while he was
completely cut in half he was able to
tell the police very quickly what
happened to him and then he died because
obviously he took a minute for the
police to get there he still had his
watch do you think he was like
[Applause]
yo and where was this in the bottom half
like did it was it still it was true it
was there it just wasn't there it wasn't
there it was near him he was like and he
was like he was like what's your name he
was and he reached into his pocket and
get his wallet yeah flip my legs over
it's in the back pocket
though
okay we're gonna move on here uh this is
another fun one here
[Applause]
this kid here uh his name's Robbie Ross
Robbie Ross is a good kid here Robbie
Ross his mom was a bit of a wild lady
and uh she had a pension for Dayton
um Bad Dudes and she like this one
Hell's Angel in particular so she's
dating a legit Hells Angel member uh
named Derek it's her boyfriend and
um Derek likes to occasionally smoke
meth and and [ __ ] guys
oh okay so yeah uh he gets kicked out of
the Hell's Angels for which part not the
myth well that's what I wanted to know
this is the hell's [ __ ] age yes we
know the Altamonte Stories the murder
yeah the [ __ ] fights what do you
think you'd have to do to get kicked out
of the Hell's Angel probably [ __ ]
another dude no let's take a listen what
did Derek have to do to get kicked out
of the Hell's Angels he he did a bunch
of meth and uh because because this this
well you know this was a pattern [ __ ]
you know he he'd get real high on meth
and he'd come back sobered up and cry to
my mom about like you know like oh I
just I slept with a dude oh I like I you
know I I got blown by this guy I don't
know I I don't know what I'm doing I'm
crying about it
can I tell you I had a friend of mine
you didn't cry when that guy licked your
dick no no no but just to be fair it was
my [ __ ]
okay okay
okay but but like
but like I had a friend of mine who can
he he was like he hey
a transgender dude blew him
and I was like oh and I was like do you
think you're
and I was just asking I mean no big deal
I go do you have like bisexual
Tendencies is that something you're into
and he goes
I'm not gay he sucked my dick and I was
like um
I think do you know what I'm saying like
yeah there's a line that I still stands
out in the movie pecker with Eddie
Furlong it's John Waters film some shot
in Baltimore and I'm a big fan and uh
there's a male stripper and a guy blows
them and they're telling him he's gay
and he's in his bottom racks and he's
like I ain't gay he blew me I didn't
blow him yeah
yeah there's two parts of that equation
yeah yeah okay yeah there's you and then
there's the gay club
all right
by the way whatever you want to do you
know so again it's Gotta Be You would
think gratuitous to be kicked out of the
Hell's Angels seems like it the final
straw and you know obviously the AJ's
didn't know about that but what they did
find out about
was that he he had
he had a he had a guy with Down Syndrome
blow him
oh
what that's their line
man
that's it for the house Angels man
you want to ride with us
you can't have any Down syndrome dude
suck your [ __ ] dick
you lose your practice
dude you know what I imagine
[Music]
you know what I imagine I imagine
they're all sitting around like eating
sandwiches or something and they're
talking about the [ __ ] what'd you do
this week I [ __ ] I robbed an old lady do
you know what I mean they're telling
their stories and this dude thinks he's
gonna top everybody and be like
hey I got one for you
and some dudes are the sandwich like
what
didn't you read the Bible right there by
law number eight yeah
that was it by the way I'm not sure
that's something I would tell another
person ever
ever ah
that's what it takes to get kicked out
of the house if you ever wanted to know
I heard not murder that's their lot not
murder no no no no yeah just the wow
dude yeah like I I just need to know I
need to know honestly like don't you
want to know how long he held on to that
he's like I could tell somebody yeah and
he he picked the guy he thought was
gonna be safe like did he picked the
craziest but you know what I mean he
picked the dude like you know all the
other Hells Angels like don't [ __ ] with
this guy he's and even that guy was like
that's [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
okay uh he lift out of his eye patch he
was like what all right so this next uh
guest was Jabar Jabar had multiple
suicide attempts
um basically he is out to take his own
life and he tries one thing it doesn't
work
he audibles to another thing that
doesn't work back to back to back or
three different times the back to back
and then he says oh what am I doing
this will work so he's about to tell us
what happened well at least we know he's
no quitter
I hope he's still with us
I slip my wrist first unfortunately yeah
it was cold though and I didn't think oh
yeah your blood's gonna clot very
quickly and it did you sliced your wrist
and because it was cold the blood
clotted and so you didn't bleed out
okay that's what he does first
right
now that doesn't work so I'm tapping out
by the way
I'm typing out after first of all wrists
with an S I'm chest and one yeah wrists
oh [ __ ] so he's like [ __ ] it all right
that didn't work I'm determined to take
my life this is what happens next and
then you try to stab yourself in the
chest also did you get in there did you
break my chest I wrote skin but I didn't
no I didn't have enough strength left in
the hand in the wrist
so after slicing his wrists he doesn't
have the strength to take this knife and
put it through himself
which is now his second attempt he's
stabbing himself in the chest
and when that doesn't work
by the way I'm too much of a [ __ ] I'm
I'm with you dude you know what I'm
saying I could never do that first of
all as soon as I see my own blood I
might faint but the chest bone this
plate is you ain't getting through that
easy
now he realizes that and he's determined
to take his life so this is what happens
next by the way he might want to invest
in sharper knives you know what I'm
saying he clearly did not
he clearly did not think this one ankles
yeah
[Laughter]
so now you're just gonna lay there and
bleed out
or not really that I was because yeah I
was thinking oh this is going too slow
what's going on what's Happening oh
there's train tracks there oh hey dummy
you can just lay on the train tracks
so where he is he's under and overpass
wrists don't work
stabbing himself doesn't work and he
figures oh [ __ ] there's train tracks
here I'm just gonna lay on the train
tracks and he decides to crawl over to
the train tracks and lay there so that
the train can just [ __ ] cut him in
half and kill him and that's what he
does he crawls over to the tracks and he
lays across
I was on my back head on one rails and
then the ankles on the other one yeah
what's the last thing you remember
hearing or seeing
oh just all that's it
it's right [ __ ] here no no no you
ready for this I don't think so well
here's the thing he's clearly not dead
he's clearly not dead and he's on the
train tracks but I do see the crutches
okay
you laid on train tracks to kill
yourself and then the train cut your
legs off when do you wake up
I in January
so this was December
holy [ __ ] I'm thinking by the way do you
think I thought he's still on the track
that's when he woke up he's like January
wait do you think do you think there's a
place where they just put all these
dudes lower half bodies do you know what
the dude who was changing the tire and
this dude do you think that we got no
lower half it's funny you ask that talk
about that later
so what happens is he lays on the tracks
to have the train cut his head off and
kill him but he laid on the wrong set of
tracks and when this train passes it
takes his legs
so he now has and his legs end up in
Cincinnati they're like when people are
coming back who's like this
a ticket
and his legs gonna take it like that oh
no dude tried to kill himself laid on
the wrong set of tracks and the train
takes his legs off from what part of the
legs down do you know let's look look
by that well for one you have to charge
them is that is that right so you charge
your phone you have to charge your legs
you gotta charge your lenses bro yes
it's like it takes uh three hours for
full charge and how how much mileage how
many miles you're getting on that full
charge right
I honestly I don't remember I should
have listened but I did not can you run
extra five hours no it's not one of them
blades
you get one day dude he lost his legs
because he laid on the wrong [ __ ]
tracks to kill himself yo I will tell
you something five dollars can I tell
you something it ain't going up he's not
good at that like he's whatever well
that's also we talk about like he's not
good whatever how do you feel how do you
feel like a complete failure even more
suicidal because the three times you
know what I mean like
he said hey these these are real people
out there struggling their stories are
unlike anything how does he not die I
don't get it either right
he wakes up a month later this is the
second person who we've had on I woke up
a month later we've had people who've
died woke up in a coma months later uh
we had a guy in the last one I played
for you solve a 18 year old cold case
like this this show is [ __ ] wild can
I tell you something you get one a week
by the way one every week the fact that
this is only five dollars
but this is a t this is I've never even
bumped it to six and this is the my
third year doing this wait but until you
want to buy a house it's seven dollars
but like this is the these are the kind
of stories that they make TV shows at
yeah
like these are crazy but you get the raw
down dirty and they're all comfortable
talking to me and I really enjoy sitting
and talking to these strangers about the
wildest like we all have our [ __ ] up
stories and we've also
taking them and and put them and tell
them and spin them in a way full of
laughter and humor and Hyperbole and
these people are not that so it's my job
to be a good listener to their story and
try to you know jump in where I can and
and provide light and levity this
you're seeing this wild [ __ ] can I tell
you what story would be hard to bring to
the stage getting blown by Down syndrome
that is not for States
that's a that's a tough one how much I
make it funny ah good luck yeah yeah wow
uh all right now this one here we have
two to go how long ago was that has that
do you check back in when these people
ever they do some people absolutely
follow up they're the community on there
on the thread is very active they all
chime in and help each other out there's
people who've been like man I'm having a
problem with my kid and hey I'll be
happy to help you all right so here's
the next one we have two left this is
Brad Lutz Brad Lutz I'm not going to
tell you what happened to Brad Lutz I'm
gonna let Brad Lutz tell us what
happened to Brad Lutz however I'll set
it up Brad Lutz is on a motorcycle and
he's going 130 miles an hour
and uh loses control
all right and there are pictures that
accompany this yes there are
I'm looking at the guardrail that I'm
coming to and like I'm my body my lower
body's spinning as I'm coming towards it
I wanted to try and slide under the
guardrail but that wasn't happening and
of course the [ __ ] I-beam man of all
places to go I'm coming straight for
this eye beam I remember seeing it
coming in our road relationship when I
did I hit it
it hit me in the about the hip and my
body snaps up and I smashed my head off
the top of the guardrail my visor blows
off and I bounce off the guardrail back
onto the road
feels like
if this is my upper body my lower body
and you're looking up at my head it
feels like my hips my lower body is like
not flat on the ground like I need to
match my body up with it
Twisted completely sideways 130 miles
sliding hits the I-beam of the guardrail
turns his back to protect himself the
best he can
and uh let's listen to more
[Music]
I've got to sit up and immediately I can
see the puddle of blood spilling out and
I look down at my left foot
and it's laid over and my toes are
pointing at myself
wait so he could he's like man I need
some new Souls on these shoes yeah bro
and it's looking at them
no
and I don't realize it at this point but
there's a giant gaping hole on my side
my guts are hanging out
so his legs a j
and and there's a hole the inside is
outside where he hit is pouring out yo
the inside being outside is a bad not a
good [ __ ] not a good look I yo you
ever had a hernia
because that's you know a hole Yeah
and I went to the doctor and I didn't
know I didn't really I go what is this
what is this thing that's sticking out
he goes That's the insides I hear what
he goes That's the insides it's coming
on the outsides but this dude had a
whole hole we were gonna see pictures of
his insides and outsides for sure here
coming up
eventually the ambulance pulls up and it
parks and when it Parks I looked over at
it and
two of its tires are in my puddle of
blood
like I realized
so go ahead you can keep letting it go
so I lay back and I'm looking at these
lights and I hurt my head I'm like you
know what it's gonna take a nap till I
get to the hospital
and the next time I woke up a month
later 35 days later third person with
over a month later on this podcast than
just this I just realized that yeah yeah
yeah he's another one that woke up a
month later yeah yeah all right so he's
about to uh walk us through his injuries
now are you ready so again 130 miles an
hour loses control sliding out of
control helmet on bangs his head mask or
uh Pfizer flies off and uh his legs are
completely twisted his feet are facing
him and he is bleeding out on the
[ __ ] road where was it going at 130.
he was out riding just [ __ ] around
he's got his friends there here we go
he wakes up and this is what he sees
what is that no no no no no that's that
skin right there
the [ __ ] skin off of my stomach right
here what skin by the way
you know what I'm saying like I don't
look at his skin that red that you're
seeing is skin that is gone yeah that
yellow patch there yeah is from his
stomach sewed in back there but they
didn't cover up the rest part they
that's just the beginning there's a hole
there they're able to stitch and fix
that what's that top part that looks
like an extra piece of meat yeah they
were like put an extra piece I'll tell
you what you're gonna get to see exactly
what that is we're gonna go and we're
gonna go in deeper on this diagram here
can I tell you something first of all it
kind of looks like a wounded Stingray
but but it's so you know what's crazy is
that it's so
it's not even gross because I don't know
what you know what I'm saying we're
gonna find out
I'm fascinated by that that's gross what
is this on my back that's the hole where
that vertical eye beam hit me that cut
halfway through me
all right so this is uh picture number
two that's a meat hook they're holding
his
[ __ ] up with right there the doctor's
hand if you see that's a meat hook yeah
but but right yeah he had friends there
and they walked up they walked up and
saw and he said that's when they they
were like oh my God he saw their face
and he's like we talk about I'm not
gonna die and that's when he looks over
and sees an ambulance parked in his
blood and he's like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
die oh but but the hole in his side that
wasn't he was like I'm good with this
well
look I'm not rewind it because he says
he says exactly what this is Play It
Again from the top
this is me on my back that's the hole
where that vertical eye being hit me
that cut halfway through me okay I'm not
a doctor but if something comes in it
looks like that I'd be like what do you
I'm going home
well what am I supposed to do with this
this but dude that doesn't even look
well let's take a look at the next one
take a look to the hill keep the I know
I had to keep it in there cause holding
the Flesh on my right thigh if you look
at my right thighs
just to hold it together
oh on the ground
of his ass cheeks
oh do you lose your [ __ ] in that like
is that it's interesting you ask let's
see this oh
oh
now listen
so that hole is my taint you could stick
your hand in that that's my nut
sacks
no I ripped off a chunk of my nutsack
oh
five dollars oh my God I don't think I
ever wanted in my life to hear you could
put your fist in my tank you don't say
ripped off of my chunk sounds so
aggressive that's a ripped taint you
could put your fist in bro by the way
not for nothing but there's a lot of
separation between that dick and those
balls I think mine are a little closer
well you didn't just have a [ __ ] a
road [ __ ] your nut sack at 130 miles an
hour a guard rail yo so does he have
problems [ __ ] oh we're gonna get the
all of it here he's got all kinds of
problems yeah let's take him we have a
couple more pictures to look at let's
take him look at number four yo
oh no there's your ball right there no I
ripped off a chunk of my nut sack
so does that mean a ball falls out I
I I don't know
I really am I asking too many questions
no that's a good question I'm not sure
if the ball fell out but a chunk of it's
gone let's let here's some more for you
are you ready no
so this is when they're cutting my right
leg off oh if you that flap of skin is
on the right side in my ass crack you
can see the bone sticking out of my
thigh where they chopped it and now
that's the rest of my leg filled in half
long ways they filleted in half long
ways because they wrapped it around that
bone and wrapped it back up my thigh my
calf to the back of my thigh and put my
foot over my ass over my tailbone
first of all I was gonna have steak
tonight
are you like what what are we doing dude
how many hours is this yeah I mean this
where you want to put his foot put it
above his head I don't [ __ ] care like
what what
that this guy is a bit of a you could
tell he's he's a bit of a
anti-establishment sort of dude feels
like it and uh he he brought up a great
question he said hey what happens where
do my bones go
and he said you know what I want them
they're mine it's my [ __ ] body I have
a right to it's my body and they said
you can't have them it's hazardous waste
and he's like but it's my body
so
he asked if he could have his bones did
he text I seen this picture I said where
are these at
good
okay yeah it's a crime scene dude are
those his feet his toes bro that's his
whole leg with his foot and Toes he's
gonna tell you yo but I'm not gonna lie
to you that little foot and toe skin
thing that makes me laugh a little bit
it looks comical does it that was his
good leg so here's the thing the
accident takes one leg and he's got so
many problems he's like just take the
other one off just get rid of it I'd be
I'd be more mobile because it's a debt
it's [ __ ] so [ __ ] up it's just dead
weight for him yeah so he makes the
conscious decision to uh take the other
leg so now as both legs his double
amputee I mean what other show gives you
double [ __ ] amputees for real back to
back double amputees it's five dollars a
month y'all this dude seems like the
kind of guy who my Taxidermy his legs he
wanted him that's what he's saying
listen where are these at they're like
what do you mean I'm like where are they
at I [ __ ] want them they're like no
you can't have them it's human waste I'm
like they're my [ __ ] bone
do you think that's the first time
somebody's asked a doctor no
there's no way that's not the that's the
he's the first person ever in the
history to say I want my leg can I tell
you something
oh no
that's his [ __ ] damn it
that's his [ __ ] yeah that's let's
take a look at what he looks like now
that's it that's that's his [ __ ]
that's his right leg off his hip right
there that's some saying you see this
it's not pretty what they were able to
do is what they were able to do with
that situation that is cleaned up
but but like okay
okay okay
so I'm not sure where the [ __ ] and
we're looking at the back not the front
right that's his back yeah so see the
elbow that's the giveaway yeah yeah yeah
who knows
something you're right
by the way is this what it looks like or
he has to take a [ __ ] and how he like
you can see now this is he has no he has
a colostomy bag and everything he said
he's he hasn't he doesn't [ __ ] or what
he can't there's no [ __ ] there
anymore look at it does does his dick
work
I don't know if it works
you can subscribe and find out
wait yo that legit like what's that
Kirsten
oh that's right and he does have an only
fans he said people are very into
amputee [ __ ]
oh God this dude's making bang he has an
only fans yeah do you happen to know
what it is Brad Lutz yeah I don't know
what his only fan is but it's Brad Lutz
y'all
scale of one to ten how curious are you
just take a peek at that only fans
well I would like to see it he I think
he said people ask him to put like I
want to say like rub [ __ ] on it and you
know just weird [ __ ] and he said he's
got his limit so he's like I ain't doing
that
that I would by the way this dude who
sent you this picture I'm dying to know
what his [ __ ] limit is right what is
your line I mean is it the Hell's Angel
line like this this everyone's got their
line this that's what's left of his legs
dude look at that that's a guard rail
ripped him in half all right well let's
move on and now you ready you want to
move on to the next one
block uh it's our last one that was
crazy we're gonna close out on Mike
Frampton again our death janitor he's
one of our favorites there's another one
of his episodes here uh again he's got a
Santa hat on he's very festive he really
is he went from Death to Donuts he's got
a donut spot now up in uh Toronto there
and uh he's got the wildest [ __ ]
stories he's uh the the train suicide
the guy leaking through the mattress
last time that guy
um and this is the one that uh this
story right here
left him traumatized you hear what I'm
saying this is a guy that does this [ __ ]
on the regular and is in Phase by any of
the stuff he's told us but what he's
about to tell us here
this is the one that [ __ ] with him the
most
it was a suicide about 40 minutes from
here
and he he was trying to limit the damage
of the shotgun but it was like a 12
gauge shotgun he was putting Buckshot uh
through it so like it's not it's gonna
work
but he sat in his fridge she took all
the shelves out in the garage like a
beer fridge he took all the shelves out
sat inside the fridge with the door open
and I guessed he thought it was gonna
catch everything and then all you'd have
to do is flip the fridge out and take
him out with the fridge and everybody's
happy you know he's it's nice that he's
thinking about the people who are so
nice yeah he's a really nice dude right
yeah yeah but sometimes we don't think
things all the way through you know what
I mean what they did was it kind of made
like a speaker and it blew everything
out of the fridge
foreign
no
so so much for containing the mess oh
[ __ ] no yeah oh yeah it shot it out
yeah let's listen I got to the end and
this guy was a hunter which is why he
had the guns and um he had that you know
that mesh that you put over like a duck
blind or whatever
you had that sitting up on top of his
canoe uh hanging from Rafters in the
ceiling or whatever in the garage
and on that was his entire eye socket
and eyeball
[Laughter]
s you shot himself I guess this big
chunk blew apart from the rest of it and
landed in a way that it was watching me
the whole time
like a security system
but it's not just the eye it's this
whole chunk of face right here that's
just staring at him the entire time he's
clean and hit this body yeah that's
gonna be the first part of her eyes body
I gotta get that I gotta get that I
gotta get the eye down first I think
right yo
he's gonna tell you let it play
it's like it was up in the net and it
was like the full socket so there's bone
around it there was still eye eyebrows
it was this whole part like it had just
been taken out and I put a ladder up to
go and see what was if anything had
landed in the canoe and I came like this
close and made eye contact with it and
it winked at him
yeah yeah
does he say anything else or is that it
yo yo yo yo yo I would never
ever be able to get that out of my
[ __ ] brain he that's the one he can't
I would never be able to get that out of
my brain that's the one he sees in his
[ __ ] sleep that's the one Phantom of
the Opera listen this guy that's we've
heard maybe 10 minutes of his stories
he's had two episodes there's so much
more from this guy alone and that's the
one that gets him I gotta tell you I'm
not sure see here's the thing
remember the the dude who leaked through
yeah
to me that might get me because like
like the pictures it's like a Quentin
Tarantino movie it's so out there that I
it doesn't affect me sure right so those
were but the dude leaking
stuff whatever [ __ ] like that the way
your body breaks down and then it's
dripping on you oh
I by the way that was the one that got
me the most from the last you said you
would want new skin yeah yeah [ __ ]
can we get new skin yeah dude the eye
destroyed them
oh I brought up dude
yo
oh you climb up and it's just like just
like looking at you
how do you sell that house because you
know you don't get all of it you there's
no way you get all of that everybody
knows what happened in there
yeah what's the discount for that man a
12 gauge that's a talk down like if
you're asking if the house value is 550
what's the talk what do you what's the
discount for the face like you know what
I'm saying yeah the trauma's gonna cost
me forever yeah don't go in the garage
like what's the when I was in San
Antonio
we were renting a hat we wanted to rent
a house and um you know they have to
disclose stuff and this house was
gorgeous
and uh I was cheap as [ __ ]
and I go why I just said out loud
why is it so cheap and I just heard the
agent go
like they weren't gonna tell me unless I
asked right and she goes well
somebody killed themselves in the
bedroom I was like what
I go where she goes
go ahead and lift up the throw rug there
was blood no blood stains you could see
like the blood man fix the floor I was
like and they like we scrubbed it we
just couldn't get it all out I'm like so
you just put a [ __ ] carpet on it of
something
he was like yeah she goes but I gotta
tell you what happened because you asked
I go but you weren't gonna tell me if I
didn't ask she was like well I don't
have to I was like okay yo I was still
gonna run it was cheap I was a college
student I like beer money but my my
buddy was like are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
dude I
okay
the for me
the [ __ ] in the mask one is the one
the out of this up out of this the doggy
bag home bro chewed it oh oh I'll never
stop I sit down and do this every week I
hate I hear these stories I tell friends
I'm like you ain't gonna believe the
[ __ ] I heard today man I tell them like
what this is the [ __ ] show listen
chewing [ __ ] this is the best show on
patreon it's five bucks a month there's
no tears no t-shirts not as [ __ ]
that people aren't giving you anyway
this is five dollars a month you get an
audio and video option if you sign up
for your year you get a whole month free
okay you're getting the Honeydew you get
that a day early you get it with no ads
and you get it at no additional cost can
I say yes you can you know maybe the
audio Edition is probably better for
some people if you're visually set
it might be yo dude let me tell you
something
for real
for you to get these people to be so
comfortable to open up to you and
to like the beauty of the show is the is
the lightness that you interject but
it's usually with Comics who have no
line to cross
so for you to still be able to do that
with people is such a skill man it's
such a [ __ ] skill set thank you it's
crazy I really do love my job so listen
if you or someone you know out there has
a story that has to be heard if you've
been dead for 30 days
please submit it to honeydew podcast
gmail.com if you don't have your
original Tates then please
submit that story on a new podcast
gmail.com pictures if you haven't uh you
do not need to be a patreon member the
person doesn't need to be we've had
other people recommend their friend or
relative and it's been fantastic stories
so that's the patreon Subscribe today
tell everybody you know it's five bucks
a month all right it's a cup of coffee a
month and uh you're getting these wild
[ __ ] stories four to five of them a
month it's the best deal I think I've
ever heard in my life for real like it's
the best deal thank you for coming on
and doing this dude I always have a
great time happy New Year to you and
your family and to you too and you know
always keep me in mind for these you
know you're gonna be the guest every
time I do I I I I'm looking forward I
think I made some faces today that I've
never made in my life I can't wait to
see them I I I yo there were some things
that I'm just having a hard time yeah
figuring out yeah I know it's gonna
stick with you for a little while yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna rethink that steak
um please plug and promote everything
that stake plug and promote everything
you want
comediennejashwolf.com is why is for all
my tour dates everybody but come out to
Tempe if there are any tickets left for
me and Jacob and uh and then uh New
Zealand Australia in January and then
the two dates that I know of in February
are Nashville and Salt Lake City but go
to YouTube and check out family tussle
it would mean a lot to me man it's it's
it's the best thing I've ever done so
and the comments are amazing and yeah I
love it dude I really appreciate you
having me down for this of course man
thank you for doing it uh as always Ryan
sickler all your social media Ryan
sickler.com have a very safe and happy
New Year talk to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]